[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ
welt ich denke es wird mal wieder zeit
für eine linzer torte und zwar eine
linzer torte 2.0
denn die alte linzer torte die ist schon
ein paar jährchen her und ich hatte
damals auch noch eine gefälschte
linzertorte gemacht die besteht aus
einem rührteig muss ich also sagen mich
erschrecken in dem video war ich damals
noch schwanger hochspannung ist also
kurz vor der geburt und ich habe fallen
kürzer die krippe im los und dann so
großer bauch und dicke wangen und ich
dachte immer so eben einen
schwangerschaften habe ich gar nicht so
viel zugenommen aber doch es waren immer
23 kilo 23 bis 25 und ich dachte immer
nähe ich hatte einen bauch aber meine
hat schon ordentlich auch was im gesicht
war schon ja jedenfalls machen weil es
in der linzer tat in der tat form und
heute einfach mal ein etwas anderes
rezept ich habe hier zum einen diese
basis zutaten also so das grundgerüst
und dann noch verfeinern die zutaten wie
zimt und eben einfach gewürze die ihr
nehmen könnt aber nicht nehmen müsst
aber ich mache es heute so dafür nehme
ich 350 gramm ihren 250 gramm haselnüsse
140 gramm butter 250 gramm zucker einen
teelöffel backpulver und einer prise
salz ein ei und man den extrakt und habe
ich noch die ergänzenden zutaten ich
habe hier etwas milch in meinem fall für
milch bittermandel aroma etwas kakao
kaffee bohnen nelken und zimt
die haselnüsse werde ich jetzt erstmal
zerkleinern
wundert euch nicht vor ein charmanter
zerkleinert deswegen ist ja nicht
gespielt
[Musik]
mit strom klappt's besser
der frisch gemahlen sind hasen ist
einfach am besten
und der rest ist jetzt eigentlich
relativ einfach kommen nämlich anderen
zutaten in die rührschüssel ihr könnt
den teig aber auch ganz gerne und auch
ganz gut mit der hand verkneten oder mit
einem handrührgerät ich habe hier jetzt
viele haselnüsse es gibt auch rezepte da
werden weniger benutzt aber ich finde
haselnüsse sind so aromatisch da muss
auf jeden fall viel mit rein dann das
mehl dazu ihr könnt aber auch mandeln
benutzen falls ihr keine hasen ist ihr
wollt oder verdacht die butter
ach ja was ich jetzt noch machen werde
ich habe hier auch kaffeebohnen mache
ich jetzt auch zum ersten mal hat
nämlich eine gute freundin von mir
empfohlen die sandra dessen oma rezept
und nelken und die kann ich zum moerser
zerkleinern oder im mixer aber ich würde
es hier einfach im moerser machen weil
die kaffeebohnen dann eben nicht so warm
werden durch die reibung
[Musik]
das riecht schon richtig gut
kaffee und milka perfekt
dann noch trimmt mit rein und kakao und
alle anderen zutaten zucker salz
backpulver 1 1
man kann das rezept übrigens auch super
einfach legalisieren vegane butter
nehmen vegane milch nehmen also haar
vermischt zum beispiel oder eine andere
das weglassen und einfach ein bisschen
mehr flüssigkeit oder zum beispiel
geschrotete leinsamen dann noch als tipp
bittermandel aroma beziehungsweise öl
etwas wandel extrakt und jetzt noch der
krasse oma tipp und zwar jeweils einen
esslöffel rum amaretto und kirschwasser
die drei zusammen oder ein bisschen mit
ich nehme jetzt erstmal hier hafen ich
jetzt alles schön verrühren
beziehungsweise verkneten
und da muss ja echt sagen diese mini
menge alkohol die verpackt da wirklich
im teig also wenn ihr dann wegen kinder
habe so bedenken habt müsste da echt
keine sorge haben weiß wirklich nur drei
esslöffel sind
jetzt ist der teig fertig und ihr könnt
die linzer torte entweder in einem
backen backen in einer springform in
einer tat form oder wenn ihr wollt auch
in so kleinen mini boer gering denn dann
könnt ihr kleine linse törtchen machen
oder mini tat also so wie ihr wollt ich
nehme einfach eine tat form
ich nehme ich mal die große 30 er denn
seine linzer torte eignet sich auch
hervorragend zum verschenken oder zum
vorbereiten weil sie eben auch lange
haltbar ist
ich mache das so ich studiere einmal
kurz ein und dem lesen hebe boden so
dass die tat später eben auch wieder
einfach raus geht kurz mit raumspray
einströmen dann nehme ich jetzt den teig
und so ungefähr eine handvoll muss ich
aber weg legen für das gitter obendrauf
und ihr seht jetzt ist der teig auch
schön fest wie so ein mürbeteig zum
ausrollen leben könnte auch doppelter
menge machen und dann direkt so aufs
blech ist auch lecker
jetzt einfach so ein bisschen raus
rollen muss jetzt auch nicht ganz
gleichmäßig sein so ein bisschen mehl
darunter das passt dann schon und jetzt
wirklich dass hier kurz auf ihr könnt
auch direkt ohne aus rollins in die form
reindrücken
aber so hat das gleich ein bisschen
leichter wird bisschen gleichmäßiger
jetzt einfach mit den fingern noch ein
bisschen ausbreiten und schön verteilen
hier auch am rand hochziehen
und jetzt damit sie schön gleichmäßig
wie schneide ich hier noch ein bisschen
was weg denn die linzer torte soll gar
nicht so hoch werden auch ein flacherer
kuchen also nicht ganztagsform hoch
ich seh schon wieder die kommentare
unter dem video
denn die linzer torte kommt ja
ursprünglich aus linz aber da wird die
halt so ganz anders gemacht als bei uns
her denn in linz wird sie mit riesel
marmelade gemacht und es hat erhält also
ohne kaka und bei uns ist sie halt so
total mit gewürznelken usw
aber ich muss sagen dass uns die wir sie
also dass mir persönlich und auch uns
hier die version besser schmeckte mit
pflaume ich finde ich schon show gut so
das ist jetzt erst mal die form und
jetzt habe ich hier pflaumenmus aber
auch aprikosenmarmelade die vermisse ich
jetzt mal nehme ich auch so ein romantik
und hier könnt ihr auch gerne
kirschwasser noch dazu geben
es macht ja eigentlich schon so den
typischen geschmack der linzer torte aus
zumindest die die mein patenkind okay
und jetzt kommt hier die marmelade ein
[Musik]
bist du eher so team viel marmelade oder
erste team wenig marmelade
die darf nicht trocken sind die muster
richtig saftig matschig sein eigentlich
nicht soweit gebacken
eigentlich müsse erst noch ziehen lassen
bevor was probieren auch das sieht so
lecker aber jetzt schon
und jetzt gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten der dekoration sarah die
fotografin hat sich mehrere gewünscht
also wird es heute nicht nur eine linzer
torte geben sondern gleich mehrere
die erste version ist wir wollen jetzt
den übrigen teig aus und schneiden
streifen zu das zeige ich euch jetzt mal
und damit die streichung schön
gleichmäßig werden
das setzt sich jetzt meine abstands
rollen drauf ich denke ich nehme drei
millimeter
[Musik]
dann am besten einmal mit der palette
drunter lösen
jetzt habe ich hier so ein zickzack
kraft also wieso eine pizza rat und das
ist auch stumpf deswegen kann ich auch
hier auf der matte schneiden ansonsten
bitte von der matte runter nehmen und
einfach so kleine streifen zu schneiden
wenn man den rand weg das ist eigentlich
so die ursprüngliche art wie man das
auch immer gemacht hat aber ich muss
sagen mittlerweile mache ich auch ganz
gerne mit dem spritzbeutel zeige ich
euch auch gleich aber das hat schon auch
schon jetzt legte hier die streifen im
gittermuster drüber ich muss sagen das
ist halt schon so ein bisschen
aufwendiger wie sie die linzer torte bei
dem aus steht zum gitter oder diesmal
mit wie viel liebe die oma das zugeredet
wie heißt sie die oma oma gerda hallo
oma gerda ich hoffe dass meine
linzertorte mindestens genauso gut
schmeckt wie deine aber der wunsch da
wird nichts sagen die schmeckt besser
als bei der oma da wird sagen die
schmeckt bei der oma gerda besser aber
ist okay für mich
ich nehme ich jetzt kurz die kleine
reform sie hat nämlich noch lang gemacht
und wer das jetzt mit dem spritzbeutel
macht dann sollte das ein bisschen
weicher sein das heißt da gebe ich jetzt
einfach noch milch dazu und die
haselnüsse die sollten auch ein bisschen
feiner gemahlen seien deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier einfach noch mal eine feinere
portion gemacht zum weicher werden
lassen
gebe ich mir nicht dazu verführen schutz
und das ist eigentlich schon so die zeit
sparen muss man sagen
und dann kommt dieser teig in einen
spritzbeutel wenn ihr habt geht auch
eine gepäck presse da müsst ihr den teig
auch nicht so ganz lustig machen also
flüssig ist er nicht aber du bist
streichfähige als letzter festival
gezeigt verstanden könnt ihr das gitter
einfach damit auf spritzen
[Musik]
und weil es hübsch aussieht auch nur am
rande oder so eine umrandung ist schon
schon so muss wenn man es ganz perfekt
haben will macht man hier noch den rand
weg aber es wäre natürlich noch was wird
perfektionisten
also ich kann dir eigentlich schon
backen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
okay vielleicht will ich die auch kurz
perfekt machen
damit geöffneten armen offen
das verläuft aber ein bisschen im
backofen also das muss ich auch sagen
die kommt jetzt auch in den backofen und
die dritte möglichkeit wäre für eine
schöne dekoration dass ihr den weg wenn
er noch so schön fest ist als sternchen
aus schlecht und die steinchen obendrauf
legt vielleicht mache ich das auch noch
[Musik]
eine linzer torte linzertorte das stimmt
jetzt
kennst du keine linzer torte mit den
mustern darf ich glaube das ist mir
schon mal gesagt okay warte warte ich
habe hier in der dritten portion habe
ich noch keine butter drin und auch
keine ich mach dir die vegan ok und dann
probierst du später die linzer torte und
das und was davon gehört
oh mein gott ich packte er den satz ich
mach sie vegan also sehr gut denn ich
hatte die mutter schon abgewogen aber
noch nicht rein als ich mache es vegane
butter reinlassen weg und ich mache
einen esslöffel leinsamen gekommen jetzt
einfach mit dem mörser und dann den teig
so zubereiten
wieder andere auch und dann darf denn es
später die veganer probieren und volkan
ok und benny vielleicht noch so gut so
alle veganer artikel chronische
schlimmer machen den videoclip was war
da jetzt eigentlich von mir manchmal
kommt einfach nicht wohl einsam denn ist
veganerin satt hatte mache ich jetzt mit
sternchen
taxis offerte denis thomalla
hier sind jetzt die linzer torten jetzt
wird verkostet was ich noch sagen wollte
wenn ihr einen kleinen rest noch habt
dann könnt ihr zum beispiel noch so
kleine sternchen backen ja für die deko
aber man hat ja immer so am ende weil
man legt ja immer so eine handvoll weg
und dann macht man sie dick oben drauf
und habe immer noch so eine mini
handvoll und daraus macht man einfach
kekse okay ich habe jetzt hier die
klassische version die vegane version
die jungs oma gerda und sally version
also kommt wir probieren jetzt einfach
ein stück kommt auf jeden fall dennis
volkan wenn es leider schon weg sarah
was ich aber dass du sagen musst
linzertorte das ist die linse doppel
brings einmal klassisch windsor familie
muss dann kennst du linzertorte der wm
schon mal gemacht ja na ja habt ihr
zusammen gebacken sind habt ihr's
hochgeladen also so mit einem
klassischen gitarre musikern sein egal
sagt bitte einmal fürs doch egal also
einmal mit guitar einmal gespritzt und
einmal mit sternchen
die dürfen wir noch nicht anschneiden
die gs votum wirklich klassisch vegan
auch vegan und übrigens hier tat formen
mit hebe boden einfach bisschen lösen
die hebt so jetzt und was ich vielleicht
noch sagen uns linser tage ist man
eigentlich nicht am gleichen tag man
lässt rom war jetzt ist ja noch ein
bisschen hart aber morgen übermorgen und
in einer woche ist ja richtig schön weil
ich durchgezogen macht es die oma berta
ganz frisch ist eigentlich eigentlichen
autoren haben sie probieren so aber und
improvisiert morgen ja wir probieren sie
heute und morgen übermorgen weil ich
habe jetzt genug gebacken europa london
derby holten veganer klassiker ich finde
auch die vegane weise und mega einfach
ist die grüne
ich nehme die goldene die bist du okay
das ist dann weg damit
also ich finde es behältnis von
marmelade zu boden
fragen natürlich aber es ist so seine
oma hat die macht es halt schon seit
jahrzehnten wahrscheinlich nicht so
dagegen an bord du machst die zweitbeste
möglichkeit aber nicht in marmelade ist
das flaue mit aprikose liebe oma gerda
vielleicht habe ich ja das glück und
darf man ein stück von deiner
linzertorte probieren dann kann noch was
von dir lernen bestimmt und wenn die oma
gerda was grundlegend anderes macht dann
bin ich dafür dass wir das rezept von
der oma gerda hier auch hochladen oder
fragen sie damit meint der oma gerda
zusammen
ja ich liebe auch war mit dem sattel
vorteil nämlich findet aber aber ich
muss sagen
der hase eines jahres ich finde dass wir
ein richtig gutes also statement abgeben
können müssen wir morgen noch mal
probieren noch mal so geht übermorgen
noch mal die woche sollten also links
draußen linzertorte klasse 212
jahreszeit gut drauf also viel spaß beim
nachbacken und ich freue mich jetzt auf
eure linzertorten rezeptfotos bis zum
nächsten mal
wahnsinn und schmeckt dir das eigentlich
so als diamant bitte meine richtigen
geschmack
jaja schmeckt er das es gibt wieso in
der innenstadt hat deswegen das ich
hatte vorher noch gefragt wird in der
türkei eigentlich so etwas gibt ja sagen
das nicht weil interessen die nicht
gerne lebkuchen ja sowieso ja weil
lebkuchen da sagen die marge gewinn ist
schmeckt mir medizin und bei dem wie
sich jetzt nicht ob die genau
also ich habe mich über den
kassenbestand geheimer wahl kam besser
kann man den akku aber da müssen wir
jetzt leute man den text app abgaben 6 4
keine aufsätze lieblinge in panik auf
der zuverlässigkeit
er hoffe jetzt sogar nach kaymak mit
waben honig sein abtauchen 133 tage
später also heute ist tag 2 takt reine
taktik vor drei tagen gebacken und
gestern haben wir schon probiert und es
war schon richtig gut aber heute ist
diese bombe jetzt also jetzt hat sie so
denn jetzt also und linzertorte die
mixed schön durchgezogen richtig gutes
frühstück morgens halb zehn in
deutschland
ich wollte nur anmerken dass an meinem
teller nudeln klebte woher kommt aus der
spülmaschine essen solche libysche stück
kuchen draufgelegt
ich wollte dass du die liebe zu erst
recht mitgeteilt und ich muss sagen ich
habe das ist tatsächlich die veganer
[Gelächter]
man merkt einfach null unterschied weil
es wirklich nichts doch ich habe jetzt
die veganer einmal mit sternsinger
machten einmal auch so aufgespritzt aber
da war benny und volkan gegessen
ich habe sechs stück oder so gehabt okay
da haben sie gefragt stellt das haben
sie nicht
dann sehe ich habe gestern die sterne
vegane gestern abend war es auch schon
da war sie auch richtig gut also hammer
also packt sie unbedingt nach direkt in
drei in 34 fache menge denn ihm ist also
ist es so eine linzer torte tabak war
nicht nur eine weil die erste schneider
man direkt war man die zweite ist man
dann am nächsten tag und eigentlich die
dritte vierte am übernächsten tag die
allerbeste und die hält sich auch locker
ist eine gute live eigentlich hätte die
sich locker zwei wochen aber sogar drei
teams hatten wir ja hier ist die erste
wahl und die anderen drei nach vier
tagen
ich meine wir müssen morgen noch mal
probieren
warum das letzte stück will ich mal so
nehmen so abreißen
[Musik]